- Hey guys,
bringing back Biz Dev Sunday.
(rap music)
Obviously, in
lieu of this episode
you'll see a bunch of B-roll.
You'll see some stuff
from the meetings some daps.
Actually we didn't
film the second meetings.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Had a pretty
hardcore meeting, the second.
After we did the little
film that you just watched
with the burger thing.
But first, let's
look at this burger.
I mean you did a nice job, man.
- I appreciate it.
- It's funny when
I saw the picture.
I'm like, "He's not gonna
make this look like that."
You kinda drilled it.
- I'm pretty proud to be honest.
I think I did a good job.
- And you cooked it a
little further through.
First time you
cooked it, what happened?
- I cooked these on Wednesday,
undercooked the burger a little
bit so I'm gonna try
not to do that today.
Take the first bite, I'm like,
"Oh, that's a little rare."
I sent one of
these out to my parents,
they loved it.
It's a ton of food though.
I think they got three or four
meals out of it just between the
two of them.
- I'm gonna do my part right
now for everybody watching.
Obviously, when this opportunity
came up for Matt to do this
Bronco burger, I was talking
to the Vayner Sports team.
I was like, "Hey! Let
me pair some wine with it."
So many of you out
there when you eat burgers,
barbecue season, there's a
lot of great red wines to pair,
Zinfandels, not the
white kind, not the pink kind.
The red Zinfandels but for me
what we're gonna be pairing
SalvaTerra Amarone mainly from
the Corvinone
and Rondinella grape.
Italian red wine.
Matt, you're just
gonna sniffy sniff.
- Yep.
- 'Cause not gonna get ourselves
in trouble here plus you're
getting ready to
hit the field so.
I can't but help at this point
to make videos and not sneak in
a little bit of the thing I'm
passionate about these days,
hustle, hard work,
things of that nature.
Your career is so
fascinating to me.
Obviously, when I got involved
and we created Vayner Sports you
had already been there.
- Mhmmm.
- Tell me what it feels like in
your head right now to go from a
small town where you're playing
high school football that can't
even field an entire team to
being in a situation where
you're on a practice squad.
Right?
- Mhmmm.
- As a rook, to now
literally, you know,
obviously Pro Football Focus
is a big benchmark to being
literally, widely by a lot of
people consider the best center
in football or at least
obviously when people like to
debate, one of them.
How has that journey been?
What do you associate
that level of success to?
From those humble beginnings
to where you sit today.
- I mean it's
exactly what you said.
It's really the work ethic and--
- And where did that
come from for you?
- My parents
instilled that in me.
- Both?
- I mean, yeah.
I grew up on a cattle
ranch and we were working
from a young age.
It was well known
that if you're gonna
come out of this childhood
with one thing, you're
gonna know how to work.
Going through
the story, you know,
had a lot of minor setbacks but
just kept the attitude of well,
if I just keep working, keep
working hard it's gonna turn out
in my favor and it did.
- After we did the little film
that you just watched with the
burger thing,
we did a really cool,
really cool
financial business meeting.
Real big thinking for Matt and
our players at Vayner Sports.
And it kind of inspired me.
DRock, you inspired me to bring
back a little Biz Dev Sunday.
So for this Biz Dev
Sunday, Vayner Sports.
So many of you
have local businesses,
national businesses.
You're marketing
managers at big brands.
The things we've done with
Postmates and Braxton Miller.
There's so much opportunity for
us to do incredible things with
our athletes at Vayner Sports
that are breaking the mold.
You can get two for one.
You can get the branding of our
players and that sponsorship,
that endorsement but then we
at Vayner Sports are
producing these assets.
These videos, these
social media content that
you can use on
your business's profile.
If you've got a small, medium or
large-sized business and
you're thinking in the $10,000
to millions of dollar space,
please email right here Biz
Dev Sunday for Vayner Sports.
Looking to do some
deals with our ten or so guys.
We've got a big announcement
of a new guy on Monday.
All-Pro, we're starting to bring
the heat and so that's this
week's Biz Dev Sunday
and then actually,
I feel like
I want to brainstorm.
Biz Dev Sunday,
gonna throw something else.
I'm super passionate
about my podcast.
I want to explode it.
So, if you have a way
to make my podcast greater,
getting me an A-list
celebrity as a guest.
Getting distribution for my
podcast if you have a Facebook
group that has a
million people in it.
My podcast is something that
I want to biz dev on and so if
there's something
that you can do in return,
what would you like?
Just put that in the email.
But don't waste your time.
It needs to be meaningful.
My time is my issue so
if you're gonna email
about that make it big.
Have a great, great week ahead.
Cannes last week.
Good, good content, DRock.
I thought you
edited extremely well.
I'm proud of you.
I hope everybody's
hustling and we'll see you soon.
("Midnight Blues" by
Background Symphony)